i just felt so low i felt
alone i felt afraid i just felt like
nothing would get get better i
turned to wine for a really dark reason
and i use it to try to escape
and to numb my pain and to forget
everything ally brooke
always such a delight to see your smile
finding your harmony
it's finally out how are you feeling
words can't describe it i'm
the first one in my family to ever write
a book so it's a milestone for us all
and i'm just glowing it's it's really an
incredible day
you're only 27 years old so i'm curious
why was
now the right time for you to put this
book out i may be really young but my
goodness
i have lived like five lives i talked
about everything from
bullying to body shaming to confidence
to faith
to overcoming hard times and
i hope that through my story i could
help someone else's story
i want to start at the beginning this
book in many ways
is a love letter to your incredible
parents you talk about
a very special gift that they gave you
for your 18th birthday
a ring which symbolized your commitment
to save yourself for marriage
that story has really ignited the
internet what do you make of that huge
reaction
honestly i was so nervous i was like oh
my gosh
i'm about to be made fun of i'm not
gonna look at anything
but actually i found out that so many
people were so
supportive and so respectful and so
empowering
and for me that was so beautiful i
encourage everyone
to live out their own truths whatever
that may mean to them what empowered you
to share that because that's that's an
alley story you didn't have to tell the
world that but you did
my fans empower me to share my truth to
share what i believe in
and showing people who i really am for
the first time
in this book going as deep as you can
get
was so freeing and so gratifying
ali when i think of you i think of like
the epitome of an entertainer
you sing you dance you're gorgeous
you're very sexy
and being a pop star you have to do
those things but i know your values and
your faith is so important to you
how do you find that middle ground in
that balance even though
i share my values pretty openly in the
book you know saving myself and all that
that doesn't mean that i don't get to be
sexy and be
sleepy and own that i do have a boundary
of how far
i'm gonna go with my lyrics and with my
videos
and with my wardrobe i kind of know in
music videos
how much my leg i'm gonna show or how
you know
short it's gonna be or how low my
shirt's gonna be
or lyrics you know it being flirty
but not too much not crossing a certain
line i'm an adult and i'm gonna
i'm a woman but i also want my music and
my videos
to you know be watched by little girls
and all the way to grandmas
i want to transition into the fifth
harmony years which you talk about
in really really specific detail um one
thing that i really took away from
the words that you wrote was how much
you had to fight
to use your voice quite literally on the
different songs and how much
disappointment you were met with
i'm curious how did the group decide who
would sing which parts
well it was always the producers
and the producers and writers and i
think the label too like the higher ups
had a direction i do know that it was
really hard
being in that position i opened up about
it pretty candidly that
i am so grateful to be in this group and
i want us to succeed
also feeling like i was losing my
identity and not being able to use my
voice
that was so heartbreaking for me you
know i know not every song can be
perfectly fair equal of course not but
you know for it to have been
better than it was for the first few
albums
and you know what i had to get through
it take the good with the bad
and try to be positive and be strong and
i wish i would have spoken up a little
bit more back then for several
different things but you know what
everything happens for a reason with
how frustrating that experience must
have been
did you ever get close to a breaking
point did you ever think about
quitting there was a lot happening
behind the scenes
and then also um the pressure of being
in the spotlight and
the crazy schedule and the social media
ridicule and the unknown of just the
future
and missing your family and all of these
different things and not
being heard and people taking advantage
of me
all that did get to a place where i was
like should i walk away
like i i definitely had moments of
calling my parents and
crying my eyes out and saying mom and
dad i don't know if i can do
one more day and my mental health was so
important way more important than
you know a paycheck or an obligation
but i chose to stay the group meant that
much to me and with all good and bad i
am grateful for fifth harmony and
we are leaving a legacy for me just
holding on to my faith even in those
really hard moments those dark times
that's what got me through everything
you talk a lot very candidly in the book
about body image
and how critics and people on social
media would say some
pretty not nice things to you how did
you manage all of that what was
happening there
that was awful that example was us
filming a music video flex on the beach
my confidence level was at an all-time
low and i was nervous to be
filming at the beach in a bathing suit
but i at the end finally had just a
little bit
of confidence and i was like okay i'm
feeling good about myself you know i'm
loving and owning my body
and then later there were paparazzi
pictures on social media spread
online and they weren't the most
flattering i guess
and people were so mean they called me
fat they called me ugly they said my
body was not okay they said
all these horrible things they're like
she needs to lose weight i mean
all the awful names this is my worst
nightmare come to life
it shattered my heart it shattered my
confidence
and i got to a really low place in my
life you talk about
turning to food and even wine as a
coping mechanism
because you were going through so much
behind the scenes and you ultimately
reached a breaking point
can you share what happened in that
experience and what pulled you through
to the brighter side i just felt so
low i felt like there was no hope left
i felt worthless i felt isolated i
felt alone i felt afraid
i just felt that i would never be happy
and one thing led to
another and you know it's okay to have
wine to
you know relax or celebrate or you know
hey i need a glass of wine because it's
been a long day
that's totally fine i do that you know
everybody does that but
i uh turned to wine for a really dark
reason
and i used it to try to
escape and to numb my pain and i ended
up drinking
and i was so enabled that i could barely
speak
i think if i would have had one more i
would have landed in the hospital it was
really really bad i was out of it i
wasn't answering my phone
i was gone basically and will or my man
or man tour manager he had a feeling
he's like
she's not answering her phone he got a
hotel key
and he's like something's wrong and he
went into my room when he saw me and he
basically just
rescued me and spoke life to me said why
are you doing this why and he prayed
over me and he gave me life
and and that moment was such a
rock bottom for me and i was embarrassed
to admit it
but i knew i had to because there's so
many people who feel like that today
and feel like hope is gone and
that could lead to such just a
destructive
pattern that will ruin your life and i'm
so thankful that only happened one time
and he came to get me and although you
know it was
hard a lot you know still happened and
it took a while for me to fully get back
to myself
i overcame that god's peace was there
and he really did help me
to overcome such a dark moment i am so
thankful that you found
the bright spot in that really dark time
you mentioned in the book
that you were the last one on board with
throwing in the towel and saying i think
the group
is better off if we go our separate ways
did you want to keep the group going
yes i oh my gosh i
wanted so badly for us to continue on
you know i'm like
no there's a christmas album left
there's one more album left
there's this tour of something was left
something was left but you know not
everybody felt that way and i had to
process that
and i had to ultimately respect that
even though i didn't agree
and even though i was sad and even like
a bit disappointed and even a bit like
angry
i had to let go of that and respect it
and once i
did the unbelievable feeling of
oh my gosh i'm going to finally be able
to pursue the dream that's been in my
heart since i was a very young girl
being a solo artist it was the most
magical feeling
because the group is such a big topic
that you discuss
in finding your harmony i'm curious did
you send the book to the girls have you
heard any reaction or response
i haven't heard anything yet but i know
they're so proud and we support each
other whenever we can
and that's the best thing and everybody
honestly right now is just
on their own and living their own dreams
i think they're going to be really happy
i'm sure you'll see some love on social
media
[Music]
2018 the rebirth of ali brooke you're a
solo artist
you found yourself a recording deal but
you detail in the book that it wasn't an
easy ride
did you have a plan b oh my gosh so
yes that was so hard being faced with
rejection
especially because i was you know
prepped
to think it was gonna be the total
opposite and there was no other
doors that were open or available was
completely devastating i didn't know if
i was ever gonna make music
again or be able to and at that time
i mean we were going to figure it out i
was going to figure it out i'm a fighter
you know and that was one of the most
phenomenal feelings
ever and it was just so victorious i
felt redeemed
and i was so unbelievably thankful the
less
there's to not give up and to not lose
hope and
even when it feels like i have no idea
what's gonna happen
i'm so thankful that that story had a
very happy ending
me too you mentioned your manager will a
little earlier
and you talk about him quite a lot in
the book how he's
also a man of faith he's been an
incredible support system to you
what kind of a confidante person has he
been for you
just having someone who knows who i am
who understands my vision
knows everything i went through and has
my back no matter what
is someone i can trust means everything
it means that i'm not alone and
someone's not going to give up on me
it's quite beautiful you've hinted here
and there
that will is very very special to you
is he your special someone um
no of course someone who has that much
history
and love and who's loyal is special you
know so
i like to keep those people around is it
just professional
yes just profession of okay so with that
you're a published author you're a
global
singing superstar you're now an actress
how do you find time for a personal life
oh there's no personal life to be had
nothing i'm just i'm just kidding i
really don't
have much of a personal life because i'm
so focused on work but that's totally
okay with me
i truly feel happiest when i'm doing
what i love
that's the best thing in right now i i
am in atlanta
shooting my very first film and it's
beyond special and so incredible
and it's called high expectations and
it's a dream come true
you're working with kelsey grammer what
has the experience been like
this is my jaws of the floor that i'm
going to be working with kelsey grammer
he is such a legend you're definitely
going to see a different side of me and
i'm so excited to show this
i think i can speak on behalf of the
entire allegiance that we are
so excited to see you be a force on our
screens but i would be remiss to sit
here and not ask you what kind of an
effect that has on music
so what's super awesome is that i am
still
just putting out music and song after
song every song
and i'm going to continue to pump out
music through the rest of the year
so that's super exciting you know music
will always be
my number one and my home and my
foundation and
in the meanwhile i'll be able to also do
the other things that i love
you